تقف بالمطبخ تمام
تعدل على الوصفات وصفات الطعام لاعدادها
بطريقه صحيه ندى العادي مشاهدينا هي شاف
فلسطينيه الكعك والكوكيز والمخبوزات
المختلفه بطرق صحيه وبدون مواد حافظه
وكيميائيه
تعد وتعد لنا ايضا اليوم وعلى الهواء بعد
الاصناف ببصمتها الخاصه منها هذا اللي
حيرني مطبق الزعتر الاخضر شلون مطبق زعتر
الله الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تنضم الينا من هنا من دبي الشيف ندى
العايدي شيف صباح الخير صباح الخير صباح
الذائقه صباح النكهات اهلا
وسهلا شيف ندى يعني انا من امس وانا قاعد
اقول يا ربي المطبق مطبق اذا كان على طريق
الطريق الكويتيه او العراقيين او كذا فهو
يصير الرز
مع
الماي او الصوص تبع الاكله نفسها اذا رحنا
على السعوديه فهو عباره عن العجين المرقوق
وبالتالي بيعمل بطريقه كانه فطائر فطير
مشلتت او غيره
لكن شف ندى شلون اليوم والزعتر اخضر كيف
نعم اهلا وسهلا طبعا المطبق من الاشياء
الموجود باكثر من مطبخ وطبعا المطبخ
الفلسطيني بتميز بنكهته الخاصه فاكيد
الفيرجن الفلسطينيه من المطبق حيكون فيها
زيت الزيتون وحيكون فيها الزعتر وكمان
حيكون فيها السماق فانا اليوم جهزت المطبق
الزعتر من قبل بس حابه افرجيكم هيك
الطريقه على السريع كمان وانا عم بحكي معك
شيف ندى اذا بتقدري يعني انا الحقيقه احن
الى خبز واحن الى رائحه المخبوزات
الفلسطينيه اللي تعودت عليها في القدس
بصراحه شفت ندى الكعك وكل المخبوزات شو
اللي بميز المخبوزات المخبوزات الفلسطينيه
تحديدا
خصوصا لما انت عم بتقولي يعني مطبق زعتر
المطبق انا حسب ما بعرفه حلو حلو بكون مع
جبنه ومع قطر وكذا ولكن احنا بنحكي مالح
الان
المطبق الزعتر فيه وفيرجن الحلو كمان
بنعمل بالجوز وبزيت الزيتون وبالقرفه بس
اذا شايفين معي اليوم عم بجهز المطبق
بالسماق والبصل والزعتر الاخضر انا ححطه
هون النكهات هيك تتجانس على النار حبيت
افرجيكم الزعتر الاخضر اللي بنستعمله اللي
هو هذا الزعتر الورق بيجي فريش طبعا هذا
الورق بيتغسل وبعدين بعد ما يتقطف فهيك
بصير شكله فانا هون حطيت البصل على النار
يا ريت لو بعدين حطيت عليه كمان زيت
الزيتون شفنا بالزبط شو عم تعملي لانه
تمام هاي زيت الزيتون
الكعك اللي قدامك اذا تكرمتوا ايضا ايوه
تمام والله شكله لذيذ تمام هيك شوي
تمام تمام طيب نعيد لكان نعيد لكان
الخطوات حطيتهم زيت الزيتون بعدين حطيت
البصل وخليتهم يتحمروا شوي يعني بيتقلى
البصل بيضل لونه ابيض بعدين هذا الزعتر
الاخضر مثل ما حكيت لكم هو مقطف اخضر
ومغسول فراح احطه هون
واخليهم يتقلبوا مع بعض شوي
وطبعا شويه ملح انا حطيت الملح قبل شوي
وهلا راح احط شويه بس فلفل اسود سماق
وطبعا اكيد لازم نحط السماق بالضبط ايه
انا لسه متذكره وهيك صارت الحشوه جاهزه
تمام يعني هي هاي النكهات الطيبه اكيد ما
بننساها بسهوله طبعا والعجينه
العاديه الاخضر عجينه رقيقه
[موسيقى]
تمام اكيد المطبق بينعمل دائما بعجينه
رقيقه طبعا العجينه بس تتكون من طحين
الاسمر والماء وشويه ملح وفينا نحط شويه
لبن روب وبنخليها يعني ترتاح من قبل بليله
عشان تاخذ وقتها هيك بالارتياح وتفرد معنا
بسهوله
افرجيكم هون طريقه التطبيق راح احطه شويه
زيت زيتون
وبعدين طبعا العجين بتكون مرتاحه عندنا
بعدين بنحط الحشوه بالنص وبنطبقها
انا انا اللي عملته حسستك جديه كثير مع
انه يعني اللي بيشوف مطبق الزعتر لازم
يبتسم
ويكون سعيد
هيني معكم ان شاء الله الله نعم طيب خليني
خليني
اليوم اليوم هذه
المكونات تبقى يعني الخميره او العجينه
تبقى اكثر من اكثر من طبقه
طبقتين بالضبط
مليانه بالزعتر ايه انا بحب هيك اعمله بحب
انه اعمله يكون مني طبعا هلا العجين لازم
ترتاح كمان مره شوي ونرجع نفردها مره
ثانيه عشان تطلع رقيقه زي اللي خبزتهم
انتخابزت لنا جزء جاهز يعني هذا اللي
امامنا صحيح
طبعا لما بترتاحي العجين بيكون اسهل
بالفرد معانا فبنقدر بعدين نفردها كمان
تصير رقيقه اكثر طب وهاي العجينه ممكن
حبيتها افرجيكم اليوم ممكن نكسر لنا واحده
من من اللي امامك من المطبق ونشوف كيف
يصير
اذا سمحتي تفضلي تمام مثلا افرجيكم هذه
هلا انا بحب احط عليها كمان حبوب لانها
كثير مفيده بذور القرع ونوار الشمس شايفين
هي بتكون الخبزه طريه تمام فهي بتكون هيك
الطبقات من جوا من الزعتر والبصل والسماعه
اتمنى تكون واضحه بالصوره عندكم
طبعا الريحه اكيد بتشهي كتير زيت الزيتون
والسماء والبصل يعني لا يقاوم ابعاد البطل
بتمنى هلا لو بقدر اعملكم زياره اذوقكم
اياه يا ريت والله منتظرينك منتظرين
اي شيء اخر
بالضبط صح في حشوات متنوعه في ناس بتحب
الجبنه في ناس بتحب السبانخ في ناس بتحب
جبنه مع سبانخ ومثل ما تفضلتي قبل شوي
بخصوص الحلو ممكن تنعمل كمان بالجوز
والقرفه ومنحط فيها عسل يعني اي طريقه
تحلايه بحبها الواحد لانه اكيد هذه
الوصفات وصفات الجدات فكانوا نفس العجينه
يستعملوها للمالح والحلو فبكون يعني صحه
وهنا على اللي يشوفوا صحه وهنا على اللي
راح ياكل بس سؤال اخير اللي هو كم الوقت
نحطه بالفرن وعلى اي درجه حراره
بنحطها على حراره 180 وبنخليه يعني ليتحمر
تقريبا بده 15 دقيقه انا كنت كمان بدي
احكي شغله انه نفس حشوه
الزعتر نقدر نعمل منها هذا الكوكيز اللي
هو بيكون كثير مناسب كمان للناس اللي هي
ممكن الفطائر بتكون الشلف لايف تبعها اقل
من الزعتر فهذه كمان افكار ثانيه ممكن
الواحد يعملها بتكون ناشفه اكثر فبتكون
الواحد بقدر ياخدها هناك صحه وهنا للي
يشوفوا شكرا جزيلا للشيف ندى العايدي
يعطيك الف عافيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات